let's say I have the molecule sodium
sodium chloride we know in this
situation let's look at the periodic
table sodium it's an alkali metal it has
one valence electron it's in Group one
and so when it only has one it really
wants to give it away and chloride or
chlorine chlorine is a halogen it's only
one away it just needs one electron to
become to have full eight valence
electrons in its outermost shell so it
really wants to take one electron and
we've talked about this story multiple
times especially early in the chemistry
playlist and we know what's going to
happen
sodium since it wants to lose an
electron it's going to lose its electron
and it's going to give it to chlorine
and chlorine is going to gain it and so
you're going to have a situation where
sodium is going to have a plus one
charge because it lost an electron and
then chlorine will have a minus one
charge because it gained an electron and
then they'll be attracted to each other
because this one is now a positive atom
and that one's now a negative atom and
just just the Coulomb force will make
them want to be with each other and we
call it this we call this of course an
ionic bond I haven't taught you anything
you don't know yet an ionic bond you
literally had a loss of electron from
one compound to another now that's a
very cut and dry situation but we saw
other situations where it wasn't quite
as cut and dry
for example h2o where you have a oxygen
oxygen but you've seen this multiple
times already if you're watching this
playlist in order and it's bonded to two
hydrogen's but we know that oxygen is
much much more in fact nitrogen oxygen
and fluorine are the most
electronegative atoms which means that
they like to hog electrons the most so
when you have oxygen bond with pretty
much anything but in particular this
case hydrogen it's going to it's going
to pull most of the electrons in its
direction so even though these are
covalent bonds the hydrogen is still
sharing the electrons that it's that
it's bonded with oxygen most of the
electrons spend most of their time on
the oxygen side
of this whole affair so you have a
partial negative charge on the oxygen
end of the molecule and you have partial
positive charges on the hydrogen and we
talked about this and this will leads to
hydrogen bonding and all of that but
we're going to do here is introduce it's
almost an intellectual tool where we
know that this isn't an ionic bond we
know that this is actually a covalent
bond that these this atom is shared but
we it spends most of its time at the
most at the more electronegative atom
that's why you have this partial
negative charge so we create this
convention called oxidation states let
me write that down and I'll clarify what
the word means in a second oxidation
states oxidation state and this is
essentially assigning you know it with
an ionic compound you naturally assign a
charge because each atom really does
have a charge but let's say we want to
live in a world where we we don't like
this partial charge partial negative we
want to say look if this were
hypothetically if this were a ionic
ionic bond what would it look like who
would gain the electron and who would
lose the electron so in the case of
water if you were forced to say okay who
gained the electron you say oxygen
gained two electrons from the hydrogen's
and the hydrogen's lost each one
electron to the oxygen so the hydrogen
would have a plus one charge each of
them and then the oxygen would have a
minus 2 charge now I want to be very
clear with this this isn't what really
happened this is just our little
intellectual game that we're playing
called an oxidation state it's going to
be really useful later to understand why
some reactions occur but I just want to
be very clear this is a hypothetical
charge if these were ionic bonds so
you're just saying whoever is the more
electronegative and remember
electronegativity it goes from the
bottom left to the top right so these
are the most electronegative atoms which
means they love to hog electrons the
most these are the least or you could
also call them the most electropositive
which means they'd like to give away
is the most so what you do is you say
okay the more electronegative let's just
say that they actually get they actually
get the electrons and that the more
electropositive atoms they give the
electrons even though we know that it's
something in between a tax-free partial
now these numbers these hypothetical I
and as a well I guess we could call it
hypothetical ionization of these
hydrogen molecules this is called their
oxidation number oxidation number the
oxidation number of hydrogen in h2o so
an h2o the oxidation number of hydrogen
is plus one so we could write we could
write a plus one for each of the
hydrogen's there and then the oxidation
number for the oxygen is minus two minus
two and the way we talk about it we say
that the hydrogen molecules here have
been oxidized and it's it's kind of like
saying that you know you've been well in
this case you they were oxidized by
oxygen and this is actually a very
confusing point or at least it was to me
initially because when I first learned
about oxidation I was like oh that's
what oxygen does to things because the
word has the word you know it has the
word oxygen or at least the beginning
part of oxygen so I thought Oh oxidation
must mean what oxygen does to other
atoms which means it takes electrons
away from them usually it takes two
electrons for itself maybe took one from
each of the other atoms so if you've
been oxidized you've been have you've
had electrons taken away from you and so
you'll have a positive charge
now that interpretation is only
partially true the reality is it does
not have to be oxygen that's doing the
oxidation so for example let me do
hydrogen fluoride hydrogen fluoride HF
I've shed my habit of writing fluorine
as FL it's I've now remembered that it's
that's elemental symbol is just F so
hydrogen fluoride if it was an aqueous
solution B hydrofluoric acid that's
hydrogen here bonding with
Laurene one of the most electronegative
atoms so what's going to happen here
once again the reality is is that
hydrogen is sharing it's a covalent bond
with fluorine but the electron spends
most of its time here on the fluorine
atom so you're going to have a partial
negative charge here and a partial
positive but we don't like this partial
half way game we want to say look if
this was hypothetically if this was an
ionic bond if one of these people have
to gain or lose an electron how would it
play out in that situation this guy
likes to hog electrons more than
hydrogen does so the fluorine would have
a would gain an electron and have an
oxidation number of minus 1 and the
hydrogen would lose an electron and have
an oxidation number of plus 1 in this
case hydrogen has been oxidized oxidized
oxidized and notice there's no oxygen to
be seen so the way I think about it
fluorine did to hydrogen what oxygen
would have done for example if I say
that you've been Bernie Madoff Bernie
Madoff might not be the actual
individual who's taking your money and
putting it into a Ponzi scheme but it
would mean that someone else is doing
the same thing that Bernie Madoff would
have done to you
so in the same way even though there's
no oxygen here fluorine has oxidized the
hydrogen now I'll introduce another word
and that's reduction reduction it's the
opposite of oxidation I'll write it in
blue reduction and this just this means
a loss of a a reduction of charge so
reduction of charge
so in this hydrogen fluorine molecule or
hydrogen fluoride molecule hydrogen has
been oxidized it's been oxidized because
electrons have been taken away from it
that's what oxygen would have done to it
and so it has now a positive charge and
it's oxidation number is plus 1 because
it is exactly 1 electron would have been
taken away from this in a hypothetical
ionic bond
now fluorine has been
reduced reduced its oxidation number its
oxidation state was reduced by one it
now has it went from being if there was
no hydrogen around it would have been
neutral but now it has a minus one
charge because in our hypothetical world
of you know there's no partial charge
it's more electronegative it took the
atom from the hydrogen so it has a minus
one charge its charge has been reduced
its oxidation state has been reduced
your oxidation state is just that
hypothetical charge and I that's how I
think of it reduction means reduction in
your hypothetical charge oxidation means
what would of oxygen have done to you
which means it would have taken away
electrons which would mean you have a
positive charge but if you look in some
textbooks or some teachers they'll look
give you a mnemonic leo says ger Leo the
Lion says ger I'll say says in small
because it's really irrelevant to the
mnemonic Leo the Lion says ger ger and
this is just a way of remembering that
okay Leo like it that means losing
losing electrons is equal to oxidation
and that gaining gaining electrons is
equal to reduction now to me you know
when you first this anyway I'm gaining
your electrons but I'm getting reduced
what's getting reduced what's getting
reduced is your charge because electrons
are negative you're gaining something
with the negative charge so that's where
the reduction comes from oxygen comes
from the fact that oxygen will may
normally make you lose electrons it will
normally take electrons away from you
even though oxygen might not have
anything to do with the reaction now
there's a couple of we can look at the
periodic table and we can guess in in
most molecules what an oxidation state
of a given of a given atom will be all
of these guys are alkali earth melts and
this is really a review I mean it's kind
of taught as something new but we know
all of these guys they like to give up
they
love to give up electrons because that
makes them stable because they have this
one electron their outer shell so they
tend to have an oxidation state of +1
which means that they tend to give away
an electron for example if I write
sodium chloride in this case the
oxidation state is truly reflective of
their charge it gave away its charge is
equal to its oxidation state it gave
away an electron and that's true for all
of the alkali metals right here remember
I don't include hydrogen there because
hydrogen is a little bit of a special
case it could have been thrown here on
the periodic table because it has one
electron in its outermost shell which is
just it's only shell but it's also happy
to get to and become have a
configuration like helium so you can
almost view it as it's very close to
completing its shell so it sometimes has
alkali earth not alkali earth alkali
metal type properties and sometimes it
has halogen properties where it wants to
gain electrons so hydrogen if it's let's
say hydrogen is bonding with one of
these guys right so let's say you had
lithium hydride lithium hydride so in
this case lithium out cuts right here it
loves to lose its electron so it'll lose
its electron so it'll have an oxidation
state of plus one and it'll lose its
electron to hydrogen because hydrogen is
more electronegative than lithium so
because hydrogen you give it one
electron then it has an electron
configuration like helium so hydrogen
will be minus one in this situation when
hydrogen bonds with people roughly on
the left-hand side of the periodic table
so lithium just to review our
terminology lithium was oxidized by the
hydrogen hydrogen was reduced by the
lithium reduced its charge went down
their oxidation number plus one for the
lithium minus one for the hydrogen what
is the total sum of an oxidation state
for a neutral molecule in this case you
add up the charges and you get o it's
equal to zero and that's that's a that's
a big takeaway that in general if you
have a molecule the oxidate if you have
an
neutral molecule let me write that down
if you have a another server so if you
have a neutral molecule neutral I'll
just say neutral compound
neutral compound then the oxidation
states oxidation states add to zero and
if you have a non neutral compound if
you have a plus one charge the oxidation
states of all of the molecules in your
compound are going to add up to your
charge so for example if I have if I
have let me let me give another example
so in this case I had hydrogen bonding
with these guys in that case hydrogen is
the one that took the electron but if
let's say I had OS a
h- o h- so hydrogen in this case when
it's dealing with something that's not
on the left hand side when it's dealing
with a super electronegative atom
hydrogen's oxidation state is plus one
right so hydrogen is plus one plus one
now oxygens typical oxidation state when
it bonds with almost everything else and
I'll give a special case in a few
moments is minus two because it normally
takes two electrons from other things we
saw that with the water oxygens
oxidation state in most cases is minus
two so even though it hasn't gained two
electrons here we would write its
oxidation number as minus 2 for the
oxygen and then you add up the two
oxidation numbers the two oxidation
states minus two plus one and then you
get well actually I'll take that back
oxygen has gained an electron because
this is already an ion so in this case
this OS oxygen has stolen an electron
from someone else let me draw that so
it's I owe a CH and then oxygen normally
only has one two three four so oxygen
has completed its valence shell so it's
essentially it took an extra electron
from someplace else so it definitely
does have a minus 2 charge in this case
oxygen has a minus 2 charge hydrogen has
a plus 1 charge because this electron
was taken from it by the oxygen and so
the total charge of this molecule is
minus 2 plus 1 which is minus 1 and
that's why you have a minus 1 charge on
O H so you add up the oxidation states
and you're going to get the charge of
the atom under question now we already
saw that most of these guys have an
oxidation state of plus 1 these guys
here the alkaline earth metals have an
oxidation state of plus 2 because they'd
like to give away two atoms we already
saw water I mean sorry hydrogen if they
bond with people here they take the
electrons so they get reduced so it has
an oxidation state of minus 1 but if
hydrogen bonds with these guys on the
right-hand side it gives away the
electrons so that would have an
oxidation state of plus 1 we saw that
with hydrogen fluoride it would be the
case with hydrogen chloride hydrogen
bromide you saw the case with water all
of these cases hydrogen is the one
that's giving away the electron so it
gets oxidized and these guys get reduced
or they do the oxidizing agent now what
about these guys over here what about
our halogens
well these they all like to take they
all like to take electrons so their
typical oxidation state is minus 1
oxygens typical oxidation state we just
saw is minus 2 and I'll show you example
which is really one of the few cases
where oxygen doesn't have a minus 2
oxidation state and then there's a lot
of these other elements in between can
have multiple different oxidation states
and we'll see that a lot of examples but
if you know that hydrogen is plus or
minus 1 if hydrogen is bonding with
these guys it's a plus 1 it gives away
electrons if it bonds with these guys
it's a minus 1 it takes the electrons if
you know oxygen tends to take 2
electrons so it has a minus 2 oxidation
state and the halogens take 1 if you
know that you can normally figure out
all of the other people in the compound
so what I'll do is I'll leave you there
for now I realize I'm running over time
in the next video we're going to do some
may be more difficult examples